WHAT THE END GAME IS FOR THIS
INVESTIGATION.
>> Sean: AND THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION.
GORDON, DAN, THANK YOU BOTH.
THINGS CAN HAPPEN, THINK BACK TO
THE LAST CENTURY ALONE.
OKAY, MAO CHINA, COMMUNISM,
FASCISM, NAZISM, AND IMPERIAL
JAPAN.
OVER 100 MILLION HUMANS KILLED
IN THE LAST CENTURY.
OR YOU DON’T THINK EVIL HAPPENS?
IT DOES, SADLY, IT’S SICK, IT’S
UGLY, IT IS REPULSIVE, WE NEED
TO GET THE TRUTH.
SOME POSITIVE DEVELOPMENTS, IF
WE CAN SAY ANYTHING IS POSITIVE
SURROUNDING OUR COUNTRY’S FIGHT
AGAINST COVID-19.
IT RESEARCHERS AT STANFORD
UNIVERSITY, THEY WERE COMBING
THE LOCAL COMBINATION POPULATION
TRYING TO FIND RESIDENTS
ANTIBODIES.
WE HAVE MILLIONS OF THEM THANKS
TO ABBOTT.
THE
INFECTION RATE MAY BE 85 TIMES
HIGHER THAN REPORTED.
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF THE
POPULATION MAY HAVE BEEN EXPOSED
WITHOUT GETTING SICK ENOUGH TO
REPORT SYMPTOMS.
THAT WOULD SUGGEST, AGAIN, WE
ARE LOOKING AT THE NUMBERS HERE,
EXPONENTIALLY THE POSSIBILITY
THAT THE DEATH RATE COULD BE AS
LOW, OR EVEN LOWER THAN THE
SEASONAL FLU.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR,
TIME WILL TELL.
THE SITUATION IN NEW YORK
CONTINUES, THANKFULLY, TO
IMPROVE.
HOSPITAL TODAY’S
VISIONS THAT GRAPH HAS BEEN WHAT
HOPING FOR, LEVELING, FALLING OU
, AND I LOOKING FOR THE
PRECIPITOUS DROP.
INCUBATION’S ARE ALSO ON THE
DECLINE, THAT CONTINUES, THE
DEATH RATE APPEARS TO HAVE
FLATTENED, THANKS TO THE
PRESIDENT NUMEROUS ACTIONS,
NEW YORK NEVER RAN DATA
VENTILATORS, NEVER RAN OUT OF
HOSPITAL BEDS, WE ARE SEEING
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF MASKS,
GLOVES, GOWNS, SHIELDS FROM THE
FEDERAL STOCK PILE.
THE EMERGENCY ARE STILL
OPERATIONAL.
BOTH WERE MODIFIED TO ACCEPT
COVID-19 PATIENTS, NOT AN EASY
TASK TO CHANGE THE VENTILATION
SYSTEM.
ALL WORKERS IN BOTH THE
FACILITIES
HELPED OUT NEW YORK AND
NEW JERSEY ALSO AT THE DIRECTION
OF THE PRESIDENT, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DIRECTED WHAT
AMOUNTED TO A MASSIVE AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES TO NEW YORK,
NEW JERSEY, CONNECTICUT, AND IN
SPITE OF MY EFFORTS, I’VE BEEN
TRYING TO BRIDGE THE GAP BETWEEN
THE GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK AND THE
PRESIDENT, CLEARLY IT’S NOT
GOING TO WORK.
IT’S NOT HAPPENING.
TODAY GOVERNOR CUOMO IS
COMPLAINING, I NEED, I NEED, I
NEED.
WHY DOESN’T HE MAKE THIS CALL
PRIVATELY?
GOVERNOR CUOMO, MAKE THE REQUEST
PRIVATELY.
HE’S GIVING YOU ALL THIS STUFF,
YOU ARE PROVOKING A FIGHT, NOT
GOOD.
YOU GOT TO SAVE THE PEOPLE OF
NEW YORK.
WATCH.
>> FIRST OF ALL, IF HE IS
SITTING HOME WATCHING TV, MAYBE
HE SHOULD BE GETTING UP AND
GOING TO WORK.
I’VE SET UP A NUMBER OF TIMES, I
DON’T KNOW WHAT I’M SUPPOSED TO
DO, SEND A BOUQUET OF FLOWERS?
WE NEED HELP WITH TESTING.
HE SAID 11 TIMES, I DON’T WANT
TO GET INVOLVED IN TESTING, IT’S
TOO COMPLICATED, IT’S TOO HARD.
NO ONE CAN TAKE THE POSTURE,
WE’LL JUST SAY THANK YOU FOR
WHAT I’VE DONE AND I’M NOW OUT.
I’M NOT DOING ANYTHING ELSE.
I DON’T THINK THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES TO READ THE
CONSTITUTION FOR ME.
HE SHOULD READ THE CONSTITUTION
BEFORE HE SAYS HE HAS THE POWER
TO OPEN THE STATES.
>> Sean: WHY DO YOU HAVE TO
KEEP ASKING PUBLICLY?
GOVERNOR CUOMO, ON MY RADIO
SHOW.
I WANT HIM TO SUCCEED, I WANT
NEW YORK TO RECOVER, I DON’T
WANT ANYONE ELSE TO DIE.
YOU GOT TO STOP WITH THE
POLITICAL THEATER.
I NEED I NEED -- GAME GAME GAME
GAME GAME.
ASK FOR HELP RIGHTLY, ESPECIALLY
ESPECIALLY, HE TOLD ME
YESTERDAY, HE DELIVERED IT BIG
TIME FOR NEW YORK.
IF HE KEEPS USING THESE PRESS
SESSIONS AS PUBLIC VENTING
SESSIONS AND DEMAND SESSIONS
FROM EVERYTHING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, THIS RELATIONSHIP IS
NOT GOING TO WORK.
I’M TRYING TO BE A PEACEMAKER
HERE.
WHY COULDN’T HE JUST SAY HE’S
WORKING WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO GET MORE TESTING
AND OTHER RESOURCES?
IT’S NOT AS SIMPLE AS STOPPING S
YOUR FINGERS AND SAYING I NEED
VENTILATORS.
HE RESPONDS QUICKLY EVERY TIME,
ALL THE THINGS HE WANTED, THEY
WANT TO MAKE THEM THEMSELVES --
OKAY.
THE PRESIDENT GAVE IT TO YOU.
YOU CAN’T DEMAND THAT THE
PRESENT DO ANYTHING WHEN YOU GOT
WHAT YOU WANTED.
YOU ARE IN CHARGE.
IT GOVERNOR CUOMO WANTS TO BE IN
CHARGE OF REOPENING HIS STATE.
INSTEAD OF DEMAND, CALL TESTING
COMPANIES, CALL THERMOMETER
COMPANIES, IT’S NOT THAT HARD.
I’VE OFFERED THE HANNITY PLAN
FOR WHAT WE SHOULD DO TO OPEN
NEW YORK CITY.
IF THAT’S THE SMALLEST
GEOGRAPHICAL AREA, LARGEST
NUMBER OF PEOPLE, SOME DAYS 11
PLUS MILLION PEOPLE THERE.
MASKS, GLOVES, TEMPERATURE
CHECKS TO GET INTO EVERY
BUILDING.
WEARING A MASK IN THE BUILDING,
HALF THE WORKFORCE SHOULD
CONTINUE TO WORK REMOTELY, FROM
HOME, SO YOU HAVE MORE SOCIAL
DISTANCING IN EVERY
NEW YORK CITY BUILDING.
ALSO, OPEN -- LET’S THINK ABOUT
REOPENING YANKEE STADIUM.
YANKEES, I TALKED TO RANDY
LEVINE ONE OF THE TOP EXECUTIVES
TODAY.
IT THEY WILL DO ANYTHING THAT IS
ASKED OF THEM.
ANYTHING.
THEY WANT TO DO IT, AND DO IT
SAFELY.
THEY WILL WORK WITH THE
GOVERNOR, THEY WILL WORK WITH
THE PRESIDENT.
IT THEY CAN OPEN CITY FIELDS TO
THE METS, WE CAN OPEN THE
MEADOWLANDS TO THE JETS AND
GIANTS.
HOW DO YOU DO IT?
TEST ALL THE EMPLOYEES WHO SERVE
THE PUBLIC AT THESE EVENTS.
THAT MEANS THE PLAYERS, COACHES,
TRAINERS, TICKET TAKERS, ALL
FOOD HANDLERS.
THEY’VE GOT TO A POSITIVE
CULTIVATED
I.D. TEST.
NOW LEVINE POINTED OUT, I CAN
REPORT THE YANKEES WILL GO ALL
IN AND DO WHATEVER IS NEEDED TO
KEEP EVERY FAN SAFE.
I’M SURE EVERY MLB TEAM, EVERY
NFL TEAM, EVERY COLLEGE TEAM,
THEY WILL DO WHAT’S NEEDED.
THEY WILL DO THE RIGHT THING,
THEY WILL FOLLOW THE RULES.
IF IT MEANS, OKAY, I WANT TO GO
TO THE GAME, YOU GOT TO PUT ON A
MASK.
NOT IDEAL.
YOU CAN EAT POPCORN, BUT YOU CAN
PROBABLY TAKE A BITE OF YOUR
HOT DOG AND CHEW IT WITH YOUR
MASK ON, AND THEN TAKE A STRAW
AND DRINK YOUR BEER.
I WOULD RATHER DO THAT THAN STAY
HOME, MYSELF.
THAT’S THE HANNITY PLAN.
YOU DON’T HAVE TO DO ANY OF
THIS, YOU HAVE YOUR OPPORTUNITY,
YOU ARE THE GOVERNOR.
IT IF IT’S A GOOD PLAN, I WILL
SUPPORT YOU.
IT’S DOABLE, INCONVENIENT,
THANKFULLY, ONLY TEMPORARY.
THERE ARE REPORTS TO MAKE GROUP
OF LIBERAL GOVERNORS WORKING ON
A WAY TO IGNORE THE
ADMINISTRATIONS REOPENING
GUIDELINES ALL WHILE SPRAYING
THE PRESIDENT WHO HAS DONE MORE
THAN ANYONE ELSE.
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE NOW LIVING
THROUGH, BY THE WAY, GOT A LOT
OF FOR HAVING THE TRAVEL BAN
QUARANTINED, AND THEN SUBSEQUENT
TRAVEL BAN’S.
IF THEY WANT TO GO THE GOVERNORS
ALONE, OKAY, YOU ARE RIGHT.
AT YOUR BACK, YOUR BALL, SOMEONE
SAID TO ME EARLY IN MY CAREER,
YOU’VE GOT IT JUST YOU CAN DO IT
THE WAY THE EXPERTS ARE
RESEARCHERS TELL YOU, OR YOU CAN
DO IT YOUR WAY, YOUR BACK, YOUR
BALL, YOUR.
NOT HELPING ANYBODY.
WHAT THING THAT CAN HAPPEN IS
CITIES THAT WERE IN DEBT,
RUNNING DEFICITS, BEFORE ALL OF
THIS.
DON’T ASK THE AMERICAN TAXPAYERS
TO BAIL YOU OUT OF YOUR RECKLESS
AND IRRESPONSIBLE SPENDING.
I HAVE A MESSAGE FOR YOU
TONIGHT, COVID-19 SPENDING BILLS
ONLY.
AT THAT SITE.
NO MORE MONEY FOR ARTS,
HUMANITIES, PERFORMING ARTS
CENTER, AND IMMIGRATION LAWS.
HEALTH WORKERS THAT NEED MONEY,
HOSPITALS THAT NEED WHATEVER
THEY NEED.
A SMALL BUSINESSES, BIG
BUSINESSES, THAT’S IT.
THAT’S A BIG ENOUGH TASK.
ALSO, ALL OF YOU IN WASHINGTON,
TIME TO TURN AROUND AND GET YOUR
REAR ENDS BACK TO
WASHINGTON, D.C.
THAT MEANS THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE.
GO TO WORK.
MEANWHILE, MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
ARE FED UP WITH THEIR GOVERNORS.
PROTESTS ARE RUBBING AGAINST
GOVERNOR WHITMORE, BECAUSE
ISSUING LOCKDOWN ORDERS.
YOUR PERYOU ARE PREVENTING YOUR
RESIDENCE FROM DOING THIS.
AND THERE’S MORE SOCIALLY
DISTANCE THAN FISHING.
HOW DOES HE RESPOND?
CONSPIRACY TV RACHEL MADDOW
SHOW.
IF SORT OF
LIKE AN OUT-OF-CONTROL TYRANT.
HOW DARE THEY PROTEST AGAINST ME
ME?
THEY SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO CUT
THE LAWN AND FISH.
>> PEOPLE COME AND CONVERSE,
BACK IN THEIR HOMES ACROSS THE
STATE OF MICHIGAN.
THE ODDS ARE VERY HIGH THAT THEY
ARE SPREADING COVID-19 WITH A.
IT’S THAT KIND OF IRRESPONSIBLE
ACTION THAT PUTS US IN THIS
SITUATION WHERE WE HAVE TO
EXTEND STAY HOME ORDERS.
THAT SUPPOSEDLY WHAT THEY WERE
PROTESTING.
>> Sean: MINNESOTA, KENTUCKY,
ALL AROUND THE COUNTRY YOU